Welcome back. In this video, we are going to take a look at one of the most powerful features that
Excel has to offer in terms of how it presents data, that is conditional formatting. We have
seen that one way to present data and insights in general is through charts, but sometimes we
also need to look at the raw data values, that is the numbers or the text that are actually
occurring in our tables. And as you can see, sometimes that is not very easy because all
you have is a bunch of numbers and text. However, when we do some analysis, we extract some summary
values or some statistics or some sort of metrics from the data. And conditional formatting is
something that helps us highlight some interesting statistics out of all the analysis that we have
done. It's fairly powerful and it has saved my life more than I'd like to admit. So let's get
started. As usual, this is fairly small. So let's go to the view tab and let's increase the zoom
value to 200% so that we can see the data a little better. And let's freeze the top row so that
Excel understands that that is our row header. Essentially, what that means is that no matter
how much I scroll, I can still see the top header and it understands that this is the label for each
given column. So let's take a look at how we can use conditional formatting to look at some insights
or some summary statistics of this data at just a glance.
Now, the single entry point into conditional formatting is through the home tab under the
conditional formatting button. And when you click on this, you'll see a bunch of drop downs. Let's
take a look at the first one. You see that we have this thing called highlights and rules,
which means that these are a bunch of rules that will help us highlight certain cells within our
selection. As you can see, our selection here is the column A, which is the simple length column.
So let's take a look. You see that we want to highlight cell rules which are,
suppose, greater than a certain value. So when you click on that, you get this new formatting rule
dialog. This essentially helps us create a new formatting rule. A rule, a formatting rule rather,
is just basically a set of conditions that are applied on every single cell within whatever
selection that we have made. And Excel makes a decision whether it has to highlight that
particular cell in a certain way or not. So essentially, we are saying that only format
cells that contain something, which is a cell value of greater than something else. So let's
say we have cell values going from 5.1, 4.9, 5, and well, mostly we see values that are between
5 and 4. So let's say that we want to highlight everything that's greater than 5. And we want to
format it with light red fill with dark red text. Essentially, the background of the cell is going
to be light red and the content or the text of the cell is going to be dark red. And let's just
click on OK. So there it is. Whichever cell has a value of more than 5 gets highlighted
in a light red background with a dark red text. Now this itself was just random. We did not
necessarily put too much thought into how we want to design this formatting rule. And we can see that
the more we scroll, basically the formatting has been applied to the whole column. We didn't really
put too much thought into this. This was just an illustration, an example. So let us clear this out
and try something slightly more meaningful. So then again, to clear it out, since our original
selection was the entire column, we recreate that selection by selecting the whole column.
We click on conditional formatting, and that again shows us the formatting menu. And here we
have an option called clear rules. So then under that, we have two other options, which is clear
rules from the selected cells or clear rules from the entire sheet. Now, it doesn't matter which one
we click over here because we have made basically any selection rules that we have made are the ones
on this particular selection. There are no selections outside of this. So we can simply
click this and it takes away the formatting. But in general, do be careful with the clear rules
because sometimes accidentally you might click on clear rules from the entire sheet and that
can actually throw away a lot of hard work that you have done while arranging formatting rules
for the rest of your sheet. So this is how you can add a particular conditional formatting rule
and clear it. Let us try to take a shot at trying to create formatting rules that are a little more
mathematically analytically meaningful. Let us say that in this column, separate length,
we want to try and find the outliers. So one good way to find out outliers in any numerical variable
as we have covered in one of our previous videos is to find the average and then find the standard
deviation. Whichever value is more than two standard deviations above or more than two standard
deviations below the average can count as an outlier. So let's try that. Let us say that we
want to calculate the mean first, which is the average of the separate length. So let us just say
that average separate length and we already know the formula for that. So let us say equal to
average and as we have studied in one of our previous videos, we just give the selection range,
which in this case would be the entire column. So I can just click on the entire column and that
gets translated into A is to A. Let's finish the parentheses and press enter. So that's it.
That's basically in centimeters, what is the average separate length in my whole data sets,
5.83. And in order to detect the outliers, the one other metric that I'm going to need
is the standard deviation as well. So let us say we have a standard deviation for the separate length
and let that be also computed with a formula. We already have a formula for that STDEV.P.
Remember that we have two functions here STDEV.P and STDEV.S. The STDEV.P corresponds to the
population standard deviation, whereas the S corresponds to the sample standard deviation.
We are more interested in the population standard deviation. Again, the range that we want to give
is A is to A and there it is. So we know that the standard deviation of sample length in this data
set is 0.82 centimeters. Now, in order to detect an outlier, what we need to do is find out which
values are more than two standard deviations away from the average. That is, they are more than two
standard deviations either above or below the average. So let's compute something like that.
We say that average plus 2 STDEV is basically, I again press equal to so that Excel knows that
I am entering formula. It is essentially this value plus 2 times this value and then I press enter.
So basically, I am saying that whichever value for sample length is more than 7.49 is an outlier
to the upper side. Similarly, I can take a limit to the lower side as well. I can say average minus
2 times 2 STDEV is basically equal to, I again take the average and this time I do minus 2 times
this particular value. So there we are. So whatever is greater than this is an outlier
and whatever is less than this is also an outlier. Now that we have these values which are
basically the thresholds for the upper and lower limits, we can recalculate our conditional
formatting. So let's click on the on the column again and add a conditional formatting rules
for the first time to find out which are the upper outliers. Let's say that we want to find
out again with the greater than rule and here we say that color with the same color scheme that
we had earlier, light red background text and dark red cell color and dark red text and in this
case greater than I just click this particular value and then I press OK and there it is.
So none of these values are obviously outliers but as we scroll along we will see that we have some
values just 1.6, 7.7 and so on which are outliers. Now if we see that we see that almost no outlier
in sepal length can be found in the setosa or even the versicolor species of the iris flower.
Most of the outliers to the upper side that we see are found in virginica. What this means is that
if we find any value of sepal length which is more than 2 times greater 2 times the standard
deviation away from the mean that would mean that it's probably a virginica flower. So this is
an example of how you can apply conditional formatting and quickly at a glance see values
that allow us to infer some sort of a useful insight from our data set. The idea is that if
we have something as simple as this then we don't really even have to do something like machine
learning or classification or anything like that. We know at a glance that high sepal lengths
correspond more likely towards the virginica species rather than the versicolor and the
setosa species. Now that's for the upper limit of the outlier. What do we have for the lower
limit of the outliers? Let's try that again. Again I click on A. Again I go to the conditional
formatting menu and add another rule. This time I say that I want values which are less than a
particular value. So let's click on that. We say that we want a cell value which is less than
this particular value which is h9 which is average minus 2 the standard deviation but I want to color
it with a different scheme. So let's say I want to have a green fill with dark green text. So
basically the exact opposite of what we had earlier. We want to color the lower outliers in
green rather than the thread as we had earlier. Let's click on OK again and you see that
we have pretty much no outliers to the lower limit. Of course all of this got scaled because
it's interpreting that as zero but we see that on the lower side at least by this particular rule
we have no outliers. We only have upper outliers.
Now we only have highlighted upper outliers. We did not find any lower outliers but that also
leaves a bunch of these values unhighlighted. So if I wanted to see what happens if I were to
range the entire, if I were to highlight the entire range of values, let's see how to do that.
So basically we know what to do when something is more than two standard deviations away from
the mean but let's say that we also want to find out what happens when a value is between the mean
and the first standard deviation on either side. So for that let's calculate what happens when we
have the average plus the first standard deviation. That would just be the average
plus this particular value which is the standard deviation and let's press Enter and also we need
something which counts the same limit to the lower side which is average minus the first standard
deviation. So that would then be equal to the average value which is this value minus the
standard sepal, the standard deviation of the sepal length and that's it. What we want to do is
find out what happens to values between them. So then we can add another conditional formatting
we say that we want to highlight cells which are this time between two values not greater than not
less than but between so there it is. We say that we want to highlight cell values which are between
this particular value on the lower side which is 5.00 something so let's just click on this
particular thing and the upper limit is this which is average plus one standard deviation
and since we saw that we did not have any lower outliers no outliers on the lower end of range
that particular value which we used which was for green that was left unused so we can just use the
same value again. So there it is and we can compute that so let's click on OK and there it is. So
these are basically values which fall between the mean and the first standard deviation. So now we
know what to do when something is either greater than the second standard deviation
less than the second standard deviation from the mean between the first and the second standard
deviation. The one other range that has been left out is what happens when a value is between the
first standard deviation and the second standard deviation. So essentially what happens to the
values that are between 6 and 7 and what are basically between 6.66 and 7.49 and the values
between 4.18 and 5.09. So let's add that as the third conditional formatting rule that should
by the way cover most of the values in this whole spectrum because as you can see the lower limit
is 4.18 so whatever is greater than this should get covered and let's again add that rule go to
conditional formatting highlight cell rules say between well for the upper limit we would have
something like we want a cell value that is between average minus the first standard deviation
which is or rather average minus the second standard deviation because we are moving from
left to right let's add that and average minus the first standard deviation and let's click OK.
This time let's pick a different color let's say yellow fill with dark yellow text that's good
enough and let's click OK and that covers some of the values of course we still haven't taken into
account what happens between the second standard deviations as well so let's do that again add
another rule highlight cell rules and we say that we want a value that is between this time on the
upper side of things basically what that means is we want values that are between
the first standard deviation only from the average and then the second standard
deviation only from the average and these also let's fill with yellow text so let's click OK.
Now with that you see we'll cover almost every value in the range so there we are now in order
to see everything at a glance let's go back to the view tab and zoom out let's do a 25% zoom so
that we can okay that's too small that's far too small let's go back to say 75% and we see this
whole range we see that most of the green values which was basically between the means and the
first standard deviation you see that they are laid out throughout the red values are all to the
bottom and the yellow values are mostly in the setosa range so that basically allows us to see
what our data distribution looks like with conditional formatting let's zoom back to 200%
to do further analysis one way to manage all the conditional formatting rules that we have applied
and note that these can quickly get out of hand basically we have applied more than two or three
rules from this one particular column one way to simply check that is go back to the home tab and
click on manage rules under the conditional formatting menu so what this gives me is a list
of all the rules that I have applied on this particular column it tells me that basically
there are two rules which make me which I have specified should be colored in yellow there are
two rules which should be colored in green and there is one rule which should be colored in red
so I can just you know delete either of them or I can add rules or I can remove rules basically
you can just make a particular selection here and go to the manage rules tab within conditional
formatting menu to see all the rules that are currently applied on that particular column
so this is something that is useful for rule management there's nothing to do over here so
let's just cancel this for now and continue so now that we know what to do with conditional
formatting how to add rules how to manage rules let's move on to another category of conditional
rules which are basically you know the top bottom rules which we call the top bottom rules the
earlier ones that we were simply that we used were simply called the highlights and rules which
take care of basic logic like greater than less than equal to and so on top bottom rules are rules
that inherently do some mathematics for us so basically they are going to find the top 10
percent they are going to find the bottom 10 percent they are going to find the above average
and the below average and so on now of course we are going to let's say apply it on a separate
column let's in order just in the interest of clarity remove all the rules that we have
applied to see for length over here just so that we can see the data better in order to remove
rules we can just go to clear rules and say clear rules from selected sets so let's do that and then
our set is blank now let's apply the top bottom rules on the simple width column so let's highlight
that row and then click on conditional formatting and say that I want some top bottom rules now I
want to say highlight the top 10 percent of all the rows the top 10 percent values in all the
rows so let's click on that thing and say that I want the top 10 percent to be colored in red
so let's click okay and we see that some values already show up then let's add another rule which
says that I want the bottom 10 percent to also be colored in red because essentially let's say
we are just interested in looking at the outliers so there it is we have all of the lowest and all
of the largest values covered in red then I can also add another thing which says that everything's
that above the average I want it colored in green and then I click on okay now you see that one of
the things that happened is that some of the rules that were colored earlier in red are now colored
in green the reason that happens is because the earlier rule is now conflicting with this current
rule and this rule has overridden the previous rule so essentially the order in which we apply
rules also matters if you want to re-add that rule it is going to have to go here manage rules
and basically that above the top 10 and bottom 10 percent rule we just want to you know
order it in a certain way so we can just click on change rule order and so we say that
we want the above average to be executed the last and so then we click on okay and we see that some
of our red values which were actually top 10 or bottom 10 percent have resumed their original
color now we know what we have done with above average although to make sure we can always
check out manage rules and see what we have done so yeah we have covered above average in green
and we have covered the top and bottom 10 percent in red so let's cancel this and let's add another
rule we know what we have done with the above average value let's do something with the below
average values as well you see that I want to format all the values which are below the average
this time with yellow for example and let's click okay and there it is so those are all our values
again see at a glance we can see that virginica has a lot of yellow values which means that on
an average virginica sepal width is less than the average so we can use simply this particular
you know statistical fact to determine whether something is well it also seems like versicolor
also has the same rule so we can see simply that whatever is below average is likely to be either
versicolor or virginica but if we go back to setosa we see that a lot of values are
mostly green and red so they are in the either top few or definitely above average so if the
sepal width is too high the flower is more likely to be setosa and if the sepal width is too low
either below average or far too below average which is in the bottom few then we can say that
it's likely to be a virginica or a versicolor so this is again an example of how we can simply
use conditional formatting to figure out some very basic some very obvious insights from our data
so now that we know how to use the highlight cell rules and the top bottom rules let's go over to
the next most interesting type of conditional formatting which is data bars it's essentially
a way of trying to fill cells with bars which almost look like bar charts depending on the
value of the cell let's take a look at how this is important you see that in this particular data
set we have four continuous variables now one way to summarize the overall amount of variability in
a particular data set is to simply sum up the variance of all columns of all numerical columns
in that data set so let us try and find the variance of these four columns let's just copy
these column headers and paste them over here and here i can simply add a label called variance and
i can say as we have seen earlier we have a function called var.p which stands for population
variance and in this case for the sepal length i will just add a to a because that's my selection
and i just press enter and that's it 0.685 is the variance of sepal length and i can just drag it
to find the variances of all of the other columns now let's basically try and transpose this data
so essentially i want the sepal lengths or basically the column names not to appear in
columns here but in rows so in order to do that i can simply say equal to transpose transpose is
basically a function in excel which when it is given a particular range it's going to flip the
rows and the columns so when i complete the parenthesis and i press enter i get something
like this variance becomes a column and the columns which i had here become the rows so
essentially transpose is converting columns into rows and rows into columns now that i have the
variances for the four different columns i can also have something called total variance which
i can simply say is the sum of these four values and there it is something went wrong with my
formula i can do sum open a parenthesis and then make the selection yeah this time it fills
if i try to do a selection without opening a parenthesis it just stops everything it is
doing and starts making the selection which makes the formula go wrong so there it is so that is the
total variance i have let's drag this column limit slightly ahead so we can read properly
there it is now one of the most important tasks in summary statistics is to figure out how much
each column is contributing to the whole variance and that can be expressed as percentages so
basically i can just divide this by this and therefore express that as a percentage so let's
try to see how much variance sepal length is contributing to the total variance of the
data set well i can simply do that by dividing this value by this value and say that the
contribution of sepal length to the total variance is simply the variance of sepal length
divided by the total variance which is that and then i just press enter and then i can just
scroll down this value all the way over here and that essentially well it should have extended
that my formula but it did not now let's take a look at why i'm getting this divide by zero error
if i click on this particular cell i see that the formula is g18 by g22 now g18 is this and g22
is this particular value total variance so the variance of sepal length divided by the total
variance now if i click on this particular thing you see it's g19 by g23 not only while you're
dragging it's basically changed the row number it's actually also changed this number to 23
so instead of making it change from g22 to g23 i want to keep g22 fixed because that's my value
over here so i can rewrite this formula as follows i can basically say that it's this value divided by
g dollar 22 what this means is that this number 22 is now going to stay fixed it's not going to
change and i enter that and then again when i drag it this time that gives me the right values
obviously the total variance divided by itself is going to be one and these are all the values i have
now of course the idea is to express these as percentages i want to figure out what percent
of the total variance is contributed by sepal length what percent is contributed by sepal width
what bipedal length and what bipedal width so in order to format a range of values or any selection
as percentages you can just make that selection and in the home tab click on this percent sign
so that basically formats my entire thing as percentages now obviously these are percentages
and i can quickly see that 68 is very high there is 30 there is 15 and there is a very small value
of 4 but if i wanted to see the whole thing at a glance i could just select the ranges i could go
to conditional formatting data bars and i can just pick one of the two gradient fill or solid fill
and click on one particular bar let's pick blue bars light blue data bar and there it is so basically
that's giving me a small tiny bar chart which is embedded in myself instead of creating a new one
which at a glance tells me that this particular value is very high of course if i were to take
the trouble of reading those values it would have been very obvious to me what a high value
is and what a low value is but you see that this is a kind of presentation that quickly catches
somebody's eye and just by looking at it i can tell you that peter length actually has a lot
of variance and now i can see it see out of the 4.54 3.07 is covered just by peter length
all of the others are very small so this is how we can use data bars to essentially present
percentages and proportions in a very easy to understand manner of course that's not the only
way we can also have something like a gradient fill so essentially a gradient fill is basically
something that has a color gradient it goes from very opaque to a little transparent and that
itself depends on the value it's the the rate at which the opaque part changes to the transparent
part the length and the rate of the change of transparency it depends on the value itself so
these are essentially conveying the same information but you might want to pick a particular color or
whether you wanted a solid or a transparent range depending on the overall theme of
your spreadsheet or whatever whatever your aesthetic sense asks you to do
now the next set of conditional formatting tools are called color scales and in order to
understand that let's revisit some of the formatting that we have done on one of our
existing columns in the case of simple length and simple width what we did initially in this video
is that we created some handmade rules that is we said that values that are beyond a certain
threshold we want them colored in green values that are above or below a certain threshold we want
them to get colored in red and intermediate values in yellow now color scales are essentially simply
an automatic way of doing that they are simply going to take the whole range of values in a
given selection and divide them across the different shades of a particular color scale
to understand that let's try it out with petal length so i make the selection i go to conditional
formatting and then i go to the color scales menu and i select the first one which is basically the
green yellow red color scale what this means is that lower values will be colored in green
middle values in yellow and high values in red so let's just click on that and that's how it is
well it turns out i was wrong i basically flipped the order around the low values are going to be
colored in red the middle values in green and the higher ones in yellow and you see again at a glance
we can see the behavior of petal length as it traverses across the different species
we can see that setosa values for petal length are mostly low versicolor are somewhere in medium
and virginica has really high petal lengths to see this in a more concise way let's go back
to the view tab and try to zoom out to say 75 percent and there we see it slightly better
the whole range as we go from top to bottom goes from red to yellow and orange and then finally
to green let's go back to the zoom the original zoom and there it is now to understand how color
scales work in a slightly more detailed fashion let's try a simple exercise let's say that i
again want my columns and i want to perform some sort of statistics on them again so i create
simply the mean which is let's just call it mean and i want to find out all the
stratifications above and below the mean so i have mean plus 1 std i have mean plus 2 std
i have mean minus 1 std and i have mean minus 2 std so let's see what values we can fill in
essentially the mean is just do we have the average somewhere well we have it here but let's
compute it again let's say that the mean is simply the average of a to a and then i simply
i simply drag this out and now we also need the standard deviation let's calculate the
standard deviation over here and say the standard deviation is a to a and oops
got the formula wrong again and we can say stdev dot p so that's a to a and that completes my
formula i have my standard deviation for the simple length then i drag it across i get it for
everything and for the mean plus 1 standard deviation i basically can enter the formula
say equal to this particular value plus this particular value and that's it then i can again
drag it across and there it is i have the mean plus the first standard deviation limit for all
the different types of continuous variables here i can again add another formula and i say
that i want the mean plus 2 times the standard deviation there it is and let me also drag that
across and that gives me the whole values and i just do the opposite on the other hand which is
basically take the mean and this time subtract 1 times the standard deviation and then i drag it
all across here i do the same thing but 2 times the standard deviation so i take the mean and i
do minus 2 times this particular value and that's it and then i drag this across as well oh well
here's a first surprise we see that the lower limit is going into a negative value here
so basically little width can't go below zero but it seems like in order to find the lower outlier
at least according to the normal distribution you need to go well into the negative value which
can't happen now here's what happens when we do a color scale on this particular table of values
let's go back to the home tab and then click on conditional formatting color scales and
pick the red yellow green color scale again click on that this is what we get you see that the
lowest value is red and the highest value is green now what can we infer from this well let's
take a look if you look at the values in the sepal length column you see that the lowest value which
is mean minus 2 standard deviation is a little bit in the green which means that it's somewhere
on the green yellow slightly somewhere on the mid side or the middle portion of the entire range
of values and the highest value is green which means that sepal lengths occupy mostly the higher
spectrum of the upper half spectrum of values whereas in sepal width we see that values go
from somewhere in the mid range all the way to some sort of a lower range petal length on
the other hand is a little strange you see that we have values which contains all shades of colors
it goes from slightly dark red to yellow to orange to greenish to red to orange to yellow to
greenish yellow to dark green this what this represents is that there is a lot of variation
in these values because in the same column you're seeing all shades of the color scale
that you have chosen and that actually corresponds to this particular value over here when we say
that 68% variance is found in petal length what that means is that these values are
they vary a lot there there is a lot of variance in the sense that values range all the way from
0.02 or 0.2 to 7.25 that's basically a large range for a particular variable to cover and that fact
we can also see directly from this particular color scale essentially we're seeing colors that
range all the way from green to all the way down to red and similarly in petal width we see that
the variation is not so large it goes mostly from red to orange which means that occupies again the
lower bottom rung of the spectrum so you see that petal width since it has mostly no green values
it has a low variance and we know that it's basically 13% only petal length occupies most
of the values that are already present in the color spectrum of your color scale and that's why
it has a high variance this also has a very low variance because you see most of the values are
concentrated around orange yellow what do you want to call this color which is a very small
value of 4% and this also has a slightly high variance because we see values going all the
way from 4 to 7 which is reflected by the color scale again and that contributes to a variance
of 15% so essentially what we saw through bars over here you can also see through colors over
here so depending on what sort of presentation you want to make you can choose the right kind
of conditional formatting and see it one word of caution about how to pick color scales though
whenever you want to make a selection to draw color scales be careful about what selection you're
doing so basically let's say that we want to not drag this whole thing but we want to add a color
scale only to this particular value only to this particular column which is just the sepal length
and here again when i click on color scale and click here you see that i get those values and
then again if i do this other column independently of the first one i pick the same color scale add
it here again i pick the same color scale and add it and here again i pick the same color scale
and add it do you see what the problem is well the problem is that across all of these the color
scales are not changing at all it's like they are basically occupying the same range over here as
the same range over here or rather at the bottom row we see the same shade of red we see the same
shade of orange the same shade of yellow the same shade of green and dark green why this happens
is because whenever you select a color scale and then perform conditional formatting with any
particular color scale the range of that color scale essentially adapts to the values that have
been selected they don't adapt to the values around it so essentially if you want to compress
a bunch of values in the same color scale you have to make the whole selection work so here
this sort of a color scale is more valid because we want comparisons of this value with this value
with this value and with this value we don't want comparisons of a particular value with
only values in its own column so that is why be careful when making a selection for any
conditional formatting so broadly this is how you use conditional formatting to create highlights
in your data in your numbers well one quick other way of presenting your work is to show
charts but at the same time if you want people to look at numbers which sometimes cannot be avoided
and you want to draw their attention to certain sets of numbers first before others then conditional
formatting is one way you can do it and of course make sure that the inference that is being drawn
from this conditional formatting is obvious to people so that's it about conditional formatting
and I will see you in the next video thank you very much